this was um
a family holiday we took to florida this
is disney
and
this is the end of sort of two weeks out
in disney and i'm completely overloaded
by this point
it was in her teens that helen began to
feel that she was different actually the
day after this photo i stayed in the
hotel for the day while my mum brother
went off to the parks again because i
just couldn't get out of bed it would be
years though before she would get the
diagnosis confirming she is autistic
living with the questions she says was
painful at the time my gp didn't know
much about autism and he basically told
me what i was experiencing was a
combination of hormones and exam stress
so sent me away in tears
helen is one of thousands of autistic
women facing these kind of barriers to
getting a diagnosis
the latest research shows the ratio of
men to women diagnosed with autism is
around three to one and the median age
of diagnosis for boys is 10 but for
girls it's 13. there are various
theories on why this is including that
girls can be better at hiding or masking
their condition and the teachers tend to
under report traits of autism in girls
tv star christine mcginnis is one of
these women
a documentary she released this week
with her husband paddy explores her
diagnosis at the age of 33. i became
quite a recluse in my 20s i stayed in
stayed at home pretty much for around
eight years since the documentary went
out i've had
messages off other women that i've
worked with
other tv shows that i've done just
saying
you know we really didn't understand you
we didn't get you you know being really
open and honest and saying now we
understand why dr sarah lister brooks
specializes in treating autism and says
the impact of a misdiagnosis can be
severe because of the stresses and
strains in sort of masking their
difficulties because this is something
we often see in the women and girls they
actually do sadly develop mental health
problems
because it's they become so exhausted at
trying to fit in and and to be pretend
to be something they're not i think it
needs to be
not just the frontline medical
professions but it's anyone that might
be involved in health social care
education need to know about autism
helen says the diagnosis changed her
life and she hopes that with more
understanding of the condition many more
women will feel they no longer have to
hide
katie barnfield sky news